m
link les attitudes les sensibilités vont
en se multipliant
le jeune n'existe plus il y à tête
jeunes qui inventent sans cesse de
nouvelles façons de ne pas ressembler
aux adultes
au milieu des années 80 l'histoire
s'inverse ce sont les adultes qui à leur
tour vont se mettre à les copier va bien
non pas mal d'un petit côté jeunes moi
je trouve
mais la chose importante dans ces années
80 c'est l'entrée en scène d'une
nouvelle catégorie du jeune qui va
beaucoup faire parler d'elle même si on
a du mal à lui trouver un nom que penses
tu de la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas engagée là c'est la nôtre la vôtre
les français et quand il a accepté nous
parents ils savaient pas qui pourrait
faire des gammes année
le jour où il ya eu ce problème là que
en a grandi tout sa bombe a été rejetée
de votre société massey qui prouve la
genèse de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui